chers amis avant tôt avant de lancer la
construction officiellement de ce
troisième réacteur nucléaire et de façon
officielle donc avec monsieur erdogan
nous allons donner le lancement de cette
troisième étape de la construction et
sur le site de kodak ou ue seront
installés au total quatre réacteurs pour
assurer la production de 4800 mégawatts
par an ce qui va représenter au total 1
37-1 un total de 37 milliards de
kilowattheures et avec monsieur erdogan
nous avons participé aux cérémonies de
lancement
la première tranche de travaux en 2018
et donc comme ça été dit ce sont les
efforts conjugués de la partie russe est
de la partie turque de nos ingénieurs
qui ont permis que cette construction se
fasse dans le respect des délais fixés
donc évidemment il y avait des travaux
de montage d'assemblage qui était
particulièrement complexe et la
réalisation de ce projet dakuyo a permis
notamment dans le contexte des
difficultés suscitées par la pandémie de
corne à virus
ça a permis malgré tout d'assurer une
sécurité une sécurité sanitaire et les
travaux ont pu se faire de façon normale
et le premier bloc doit être doivent
fournir l'électricité en 2023 au moment
où la république de turquie fêtera son
centenaire et monsieur erdogan est
particulièrement sensible à ce point là
et nous aussi du côté de là aussi nous
sommes très sensibles à cette question
il nous donnait nous donnons toute
l'importance nécessaire à ce projet bien
évidemment cela
ce projet contribue de façon majeure à
l'établissement de l'indépendance
énergétique de la turquie ce qui
permettent de satisfaire les besoins en
électricité de la population turque tout
en respectant les normes écologiques et
cela fait aussi la pose de la
possibilité de renforcer la coopération
technologique
cela crée des emplois et d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les effectifs totaux de ce
chantier représente 8000 personnes pour
l'essentiel ce sont des citoyens turcs
donc la centrale d'akkuyu de est mis en
place avec la coopération de l' agence
russe rosatom
et comme cela a été dit comme je les dis
laws un gêneur participe de façon très
active ici et plus d'une centaine
d'étudiants turcs eux reçoivent une
formation en russie et déjà cette année
le nombre de salariés qui auront
bénéficié de cette formation sera de 200
cette année donc tous ces gens vont
faire partie des cadres dirigeants du
secteur nucléaire en turquie et recettes
sommes reconnus pour ce pour son
autorité dans le secteur nucléaire donc
a permis le transfert de technologies de
pointe notamment de nanotechnologie et
tout cela correspond aux plus hauts
standards les plus strictes en matière
de sécurité et de protection de
l'environnement
je rappelle aussi que la partie russe
fait participer dans les travaux de
construction aussi des entreprises
turques pour l'exécution des différentes
étapes de construction et un certain
nombre d'entreprises turques sont
impliqués et c'est un avantage
considérable sur le plan économique pour
l'ensemble des participants
chers amis en conclusion je voudrais
manifester ma reconnaissance envers le
président
erdogan qui est mon ami pour avoir mené
à bien ce projet et que nous allons donc
inauguré aujourd'hui et je suis encore
convaincu je le dis que la réalisation
de ce projet de saint projet qui est un
projet phare qui place à un niveau
supérieur la coopération dans le domaine
énergétique et qui dans l'ensemble
permettra de renforcer le partenariat
russo turque dans une atmosphère
d'amitié et de compréhension mutuelle
bonne chance à tous et je vous remercie
pour votre attention
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs je vous félicite et je vous
salue tous de tout mon coeur je voudrais
remercier mes bottines d'avoir rejoint
notre cérémonie du lancement de la
construction de la troisième unité de la
centrale nucléaire de cul je vous
remercie tous les invités que sont venus
et qui participe personnellement à cette
ouverture est à ce lancement aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous sommes fiers du travail
que nous avons effectué et maintenant
j'ai l'intention de vous dire que nous
commençons aujourd'hui la construction
de la troisième unité de la centrale
nucléaire d'accueil on nous allons
continuer à construire d'une manière
rapide
cette unité et après nous allons poser
les fondations pour la quatrième ligne
ajouté
nous sommes convaincus que nous agissons
d'une manière stratégique pour
différencier notre approche envers les
ressources énergétiques de la turquie
malgré l'affluence qu'a été faite par
covit 19 sur le monde entier nous
continuons notre croissance l'année
dernière beaucoup de pays de monde ont
été confrontés à une réduction de
croissance économique et à des pertes
économiques nous de notre côté notre
économie a connu une croissance de 2,7
pour cent
nous espérons que cette année le call me
va encore accroître avec cette
croissance il faut également assurer les
énergies l'énergie et est célébrée zoah
dans des bonnes conditions
à cet égard nous essayons de développer
et d'augmenter nos projets énergétiques
ainsi quand il s'agit de l'efficacité de
l'énergie et surtout des énergies vertes
c'est très important les sources
renouvelables de l'énergie sont très
importantes et maintenant nous nous
avons réussi à faire en sorte que les
énergies vertes représentent 63% de
toutes les toute l'énergie de la turquie
nous avons au cours des quatre dernières
années eu 4 milliards de kilowatts/heure
de cette nouvelle énergie l'énergie
indépendante
c'est notre principale solution pour
avoir une turquie forte
des études sismiques qui sont effectués
dans la partie est de la méditerranée
nous donne l'espoir que notre politique
énergétique qui a une importance
particulière vise à faire en sorte que
pendant la production de l'énergie
il n'y ait plus d'émissions il est
nécessaire d'ajouter l'énergie atomique
dans notre panier de la production de
l'énergie grâce à l'énergie nucléaire
nous allons avoir de nouvelles
opportunités dans votre pays maintenant
dans le cadre de notre station centrale
seize mille personnes fonctionne une
fois ce sera lancée il y aura encore
4000 personnes continueront à travailler
ici nous avons 186 étudiants qui ont
reçu la formation qui sont revenus dans
notre pays et qui vont désormais
travailler
et faire les efforts pour que l'énergie
nucléaire se développe en turquie ainsi
la turquie
j'ai créé et forment déjà intelligent
fort qui vont participer à ce travail
cher monsieur le président chers invités
[Musique]
le premier réacteur de la centrale
nucléaire à akkuyu sera mise en service
en 2023
il y aura en tout quatre réacteurs et
maintenant nous sommes en train de faire
en sorte que tous les quatre réacteurs
soient lancés en 2003 au moment du
centenaire de la république de turquie
notre pays fera partie des pays
nucléaires des puissances nucléaires
nous allons faire en sorte que 10 % 65
milliards de kilowattheures seront et
feu produits grâce à l'énergie atomique
cette centrale nucléaire pour la mettre
en service il faut accorder une
attention attention particulière il faut
prendre des mesures nécessaires nous
sommes en train de le faire et nous
avançons avec conviction nous
réfléchissons beaucoup à tout ce qui
concerne la sécurité la centrale
nucléaire a qu à ça cinquante mille
différentes parties et qui sont toutes
équipées des dispositifs pour assurer la
sécurité lié à l'aï eu à tien compte et
assure la sécurité à des quatre des
règles de sécurité qui sont respectés
comme l'un de mes coliques collègues
à 10 est un des symboles de notre
coopération avec la russie nos nouveaux
projets vont continuer à se développer
et nous avec monsieur poutine
nous faisons preuve d'une volonté forte
pour faire en sorte que ces travaux
soient effectués
notre dialogue est très proche qui
existe entre nous concerne non seulement
nos relations bilatérales
il vise aussi à assurer la sécurité dans
l'ensemble de la région dans le
haut-karabagh dans les questions liées à
la syrie le dialogue entre la russie la
turquie se poursuit et nous avons une
possibilité de trouver des espaces
comment nous cherchons à faire en sorte
que ce dialogue soit développée même
s'il y a eu cette épidémie de kovy 19
qu'il ya eu des difficultés dans le
cadre du domaine de tourisme de
l'économie mais espérons que cette année
nous allons
nous allons faire un saut trucs pour
oublier ses pertes et pour gagner encore
nous avons l'intention d'inviter les
touristes russes nous assurons la
sécurité du tourisme je voudrais d'abord
remercier pour cela monsieur poutine et
tous ceux qui auront apporté leur
contribution à la mise en oeuvre de ce
projet je voudrais remercier toutes les
organisations toutes les agences leurs
responsables le personnel technique et
l'administration pour la contribution
qu'ils ont apportés à ce projet je
voudrais souhaiter que tout soit de ce
tout cette contribution soit utile pour
te mens je vous salue avec amour avec
respect merci la cérémonie officielle de
lancement de la construction de la
troisième unité de la centrale nucléaire
de la troisième tranche
cet événement a lieu en conformité avec
les ordres de nos présidents messieurs
les présidents je suis à côté des
dirigeants de la centrale d'akkuyu sont
présents également des représentants de
la presse des députés
c'est
le présent ce qu'un caractère symbolique
qui représente aussi l'ensemble des
sociétés qui sont impliqués dans ce
chantier
mon cher ami monsieur poutine allez-y
allez-y lancer les travaux
je vous autorise à lancer le processus
de construction pour le bien et les
bénéfices de tout le monde
ça
tennis avec l'utilisation et mig et
jeanne d'arc se superpose à son bureau
ce problème a eu un boulevard aux maires
concernés de nationale 2 et nationale
c'est un continent qui limite chiffrée
des regards
ça va
aphrodite l'argus entre les étudiants et
le testing
théâtre entre les leaders et craint les
alliances
encore une fois toutes nos félicitations
[Musique]
j'espère que nous allons avoir une
réunion personnel est bientôt entendue
j'espère beaucoup félicitations à tous
merci